it is a wonderful wonderful night and
we're here and we're together and that's
the important thing we're together and
actually more important than that we
have some rum yeah and more important
than that we're together is that we get
to be a part when this is done what does
that mean well I just you know a little
goes a long way my wife always says if
you don't leave how can I miss you and
she says that a lot my wife says that
maybe
eight times a day now I originally
pitched that we did three episodes of
this at night we spend the night and
then we do three episodes in the morning
like we camp here oh
oh I would do that really yeah you were
the holdout I am I'm okay listen I think
hey guys listen doing it this way did
you hear that can you hear that in the
background
those Choppers going by those those
motorcycles oh yeah those are guys that
are living fast and free they don't and
you know what they're probably listening
to old episodes of this podcast right
now while they ride their Choppers yeah
I don't know I would do that I would
camp out yeah yeah do you camp I've
never in all the time I've worked for
you I've never like helped you buy a
sleeping bag well you don't need to help
me buy a sleeping bag like do you you
have a tent how would you help him buy a
sleeping yeah I would buy it for him
I would say so and I need a sleeping bag
and then she would go and say do you
have the John Tesh
do you have this do you have the
Frankenstein
get me a body bag for Andre the Giant I
mean that's basically what you're saying
have you ever pooped in a hole what are
you doing don't print tickets no I'm not
saying I'm saying this is part of legit
camping is when you dig a hole and then
that's where you go into the bathroom
and then you dig it it's not true those
of us who are sophisticated campers
bring a porcelain toilet with us
solostove makes one of those yeah well
actually I don't want to Sully their
name because I do love the company solo
stove but but guess what if anyone could
do it they could yeah you could warm
your bottom as you relieve yourself no I
am going to tell you that uh I check it
out on Amazon there's incredible
inventions out there they have beautiful
toilets porcelain toilets that weigh
hundreds of pounds that you can take
camping with and then you pull a chain
when you're done okay yeah I just you
don't strike me as like the camping
roughing it type I don't yeah I did a
lot of camping back in the day when I
was a young lad what day uh well it
would be when I was a youngin I was sent
off to Freedom New Hampshire and I hiked
all of the uh
white mountain range your you know all
the presidentials uh and I did a ton of
hiking and mountain climbing when I was
a kid oh so yeah I did and I was a lean
machine back in that day then time went
on yeah I marched on and I became the
sad sorry figure you know
no I I would like to Camp I I will say
that no one in my family is that
interested in it but I have taken my
kids camping a bunch of times I just
feel like if we decided to Camp here
Gourley and I would be out here in like
sleeping bags and you'd be inside on
like a really comfortable bed that you
would have brought in that's not fair I
would be at the Four Seasons Hotel
oh look Paparazzi
helicopter it's a cop leave me alone I'm
just a person hey Sona think of all the
amazing things in life that are
expressions of just you yeah I mean like
the chocolate that you had on your face
when you came in because you just ate
that what was it you were eating I was
eating a giant cookie giant cookie yeah
and that's so Sona okay or that song you
stream over and over again it's just so
you what's that song For You Twinkle
Twinkle Little Star yeah but it's for my
boys and I know still it's nice okay or
you know that podcast that comedy
podcast you just gotta listen to yeah
Conan O'Brien needs a friend is that
what you listen two in your spare time
yeah I love it everything that makes you
you makes all the difference State Farm
believes Insurance should work the same
way your plan your coverage selections
can be personalized by you and only you
that's cool I shouldn't shout but this
is how strongly I feel about it you
better choose a plan you want by picking
the options that fit you like choosing
to bundle your home and auto policies is
what the State Farm personal price plan
is all about getting the coverage you
want at an affordable price just for you
call or go to statefarm.com today to
create your State Farm personal price
plan prices vary by state options
selected by customers availability and
eligibility may vary you know what the
problem is they always think I'm Prince
Harry they see a really yes they always
see a really good looking Ginger
certainly not shut up and then they're
like there's Prince Harry and it's like
please leave me alone I'm a person yeah
I know I've given a lot to this country
with my comedy in my stylings my rap but
anyway
[Laughter]
um I'm sorry for the occasional Chopper
but uh that's just what comes with the
territory we're outside where the paps
can get a good look at yeah al fresco
this is this is living yeah this is
really nice yeah I'm just gonna take
another who needs a little topper off I
might I might need I might need her a
little bit more
okay so you first of all you just failed
you just failed a sobriety test three
minutes into perfectly fine I know you
look terrific I feel perfect and I
believe you gendered your drink it's a
hurt I like that it's like a ship do you
want some more boss uh I'm looking at
the ice and it's Sam Elliott and his
face is melting
um yeah you can put some more in there
no I would I would very much like to go
I like to sleep in a tent I really do
I enjoy that life and I've loved the
times that I've gone camping with my
kids okay okay so I you know I think
you're wrong on all counts okay I don't
think I am you are okay all right bye
okay and also I'm really good at an uh
camping breakfast are you yes I am I
know how to make I brought a little
portable like heat up Skillet last time
I went I bought and I uh made a lot of
Pancakes for my kids and then other kids
came who were nearby and I made a lot of
pancakes for them I'm just saying I know
I'm a failure at most things but I did I
do very well at a campsite who are these
other kids they were actors I hired
the sad thing is they were child actors
from a long time ago so when they showed
up they were all in their 40s and 50s
remember me on Eight Is Enough oh my God
what are you doing here yeah Jason
Bateman foreign